nvidia just announced their 3000 series
ampere cards
and they destroyed the 2000 series in
terms of price
to performance but one trend that we
have seen
over the past several years is slow
incrementing of prices
the gtx 980 came out for 550 dollars in
this then increased to 600 dollars in
with the gtx 1080 later on we saw 700
with the rtx 2080 and now we have 700
again with the 3080. the price increases
are even more evident when we look at
the flagship ti
series which started at 650 with the 980
ti
and now stands at fifteen hundred
dollars with the rtx 3090
of course nvidia has usually delivered
enough of a performance boost
to justify their new higher prices but
really
how much do nvidia graphics cards
actually cost to make
[Music]
well starting off fortunately for us
nvidia is a public company meaning that
they post their financial results
publicly thus working backwards from
their quarterly reports
will likely give us the most accurate
and reliable manufacturing costs
as opposed to trying to reverse engineer
the cost of producing wafers and
dies and that sort of thing make sure to
stick around to the end of the video
if you want to find out how much nvidia
profits from the 1500
rtx 3090 but anyways
taking a look at nvidia's last quarterly
report
we can see that they release both gaap
and non-gaap reports
gaap stands for generally accepted
accounting principles
and is what is mostly used by financial
professionals
non-gaap is generally just a method that
companies use
to bolster the financial metrics by
classifying some expenses differently
in some cases non-gaap is more
indicative
of a company's financial standing but
this is usually not the case
so we'll stick to the more accepted gap
report
nvidia's gross profit margin over the
past few quarters
has hovered between the high 50s and the
mid 60s
so we'll say that on average nvidia has
a gross profit margin
of 60 percent however something to keep
in mind
is that nvidia doesn't actually sell
most of their cards
directly to consumers at least not in
the gaming market
most individuals in the gaming community
buy third-party cards from add-in board
partners
as they generally have better cooling
overclocking
and you can often times find them
cheaper as well
as nvidia's founders edition cards
basically never go on sale
we don't exactly know how much nvidia
sells their cards for
to their add-in board partners so we'll
say
that it's about a 20 discount this would
be the same
for pre-built manufacturers add-in board
partners
don't have to do too much technical work
it's mainly just aesthetics and cooling
so they don't really need that much
margin to pull in a solid amount
themselves
also we'll assume that the vast majority
or 80
of gaming gpu sales come from add-on
board partners
this means that on the gaming side
nvidia pulls in 100
of the msrp on 20 of their cards and
80 of the msrp on the other 80 of their
cards
with that being said on the rtx 3080
nvidia would put in 700 on only 20
of their cards while they would pull in
on 80 of their cards this means that
their weighted average revenue
per rtx 380 sold is about 588
from this revenue nvidia has a gross
profit margin of 60
meaning that and 80 352.80
is gross profit this also indicates that
the remaining amount
which is 235 dollars and 20 cents is how
much it costs nvidia to actually produce
in rtx 3080. gross profit includes the
cost of materials
labor equipment costs involved in the
production
utilities used in production facilities
and shipping costs
basically if you already have the
blueprints and equipment to build an rtx
235 dollars and 20 cents is how much it
would cost you to produce the card
and get it to the customer something
else to consider
is that the rtx 3080 likely has a higher
gross profit margin
than the overall gross profit margin
lower level cards likely have gross
profit margins closer to 50 percent
while higher level cards have margins
closer to 70
or even 80 thus the rtx 3080
likely cost less than for nvidia to
actually produce
or about 30 percent of the final selling
price
but of course you don't get blueprints
for free
they cost billions of dollars in
research and development
as for nvidia their operating expenses
came out to 1.6
billion dollars last quarter generally
however
their operating expenses are about 1
billion per quarter
operating expenses do rise as the
business grows
but it's also likely that the pandemic
played a role in inflating expenses
thus will say that expenses should have
been closer to the 1 billion
mark at 1.3 billion
this means that about a third of their
revenue goes towards
rent the equipment itself marketing
insurance payroll for employees who
aren't part of the manufacturing team
and of course research and development
thus
out of the 588 in revenue they get per
rtx 3080
right about 200 goes towards the various
costs of running a business
this leaves 188 for nvidia as operating
income
at this point they have to pay taxes
which in their case
is not a lot but nonetheless taxes pull
down their net profit
to about 180 dollars per rtx 380 sold
so here's the rundown for the rtx 3080
200 goes towards producing the card 200
goes towards developing the card and
running the business
and eight dollars goes to the tax man
112 dollars
goes to the add-in board partner if
there is one otherwise
nvidia gets to keep most of this as well
as a couple of fans and the shroud
doesn't cost that much finally nvidia
profits the remaining
180 dollars so if you buy a third party
rtx 3080
nvidia gets roughly 170 and if you buy
a founder's edition rtx 3080 they get
about 200
but most people don't buy the rtx 3080
so how does this translate to the rtx
the rtx 3060 has not yet been announced
but assuming that it's the same price as
the rtx 2060
we'll call it 350 dollars again about 20
percent will be shaved off
as added board partners will be able to
buy the 360
at a lower price from nvidia assuming
the same
80 to 20 ratio as a 3080 we get an
average weighted price
of 294 the rtx 3060
likely has a smaller gross profit margin
of about 50 percent
thus it will cost about 147 dollars
to actually produce the rtx 3060 with
the same third going towards operating
expenses
about 100 would go towards running the
business
and development costs this leaves just
forty seven dollars in operating income
accounting for a couple of dollars in
taxes nvidia will profit about forty
dollars from each 30 60 day sell
on average as for the founder's edition
2060 however
their net profit is likely closer to 50
to 60
so after the price dropped to 300 near
the beginning of this year
nvidia was making just about 10 from
each rtx
this makes sense as they were just
looking to break even
and get rid of their rtx 2060 inventory
over the next year
in order to make room for the 360.
selling it for breakeven prices
also helps them to preserve market share
against amd
and considering that most of their
profits come from the top cards anyways
preserving market share is much more
important than profits
with their mid-tier cards it seems quite
self-explanatory
but of course there are some who don't
quite understand this
anyways moving on to the 3070 this card
is
probably the sweet spot for price to
performance the 3060
will likely end up outselling the 3070
due to its lower
price but this is the card to get the
best bang for the buck
the 3070 comes in at 500
and assuming the same 20 discount for
add-in board partners
and pre-built manufacturers we get a
weighted average cost
of 420 per 30 70.
this card is probably the best
representation of their financial report
and likely has the same 60 gross profit
margin
meaning that manufacturing costs about
170 dollars
leaving nvidia with 250 dollars giving
operating expenses the same
one-third of the revenue we are left
with 110 dollars
give 10 dollars to uncle sam and nvidia
profits right about 100
per 30 70. with their founders edition
this is upwards of 150 dollars and
finally that brings us into the brand
new almighty
rtx 3090 which comes in at a steep
fifteen hundred dollars with this card
it's unlikely that nvidia
sells them for a 20 discount to add-in
board partners
the price of the card itself is fifteen
hundred dollars
so a ten or fifteen percent discount is
really
all that's needed to give adam board
partners a decent profit
at a fifteen percent discount the
weighted average revenue from each rtx
is 1320 with this card
nvidia likely has a very high gross
profit margin
as the production itself doesn't cost
all that much more
than the rtx 3060 or 3080 but the price
is leagues ahead thus nvidia likely has
a gross profit margin
of at least eighty percent and this
could be as high as ninety percent
but calling it eighty percent two
hundred and sixty four dollars would go
towards manufacturing
leaving 1056 dollars for nvidia unlike
manufacturing costs
the rtx 3090 likely cost a lot more
money to develop
than the 3080 or 3060. so we'll say that
the operating expense
ratio remains the same at about
one-third
this comes out to an operating cost of
440 per unit
nonetheless the rtx 3090 will likely be
able to pull an operating income
of about 616 dollars shaving off another
for taxes about 600 from each rtx 3090
will go straight to nvidia's bottom line
for founders edition cards
this number balloons upwards of seven
hundred dollars
thus forty to fifty percent of the rtx
3090 price
is net profit for nvidia but that
probably comes at no surprise
as you guys probably expected something
like that anyways so
at the end of the day nvidia pulls on
about 50 dollars from their 60 series
100 from the 70 series and 200
from their 80 series and considering
that this is where most of us land
i think these are pretty fair profit
margins do you guys agree
comment that down below and drop a like
if you guys are pumped for the 3000
series launch
and of course consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys
on the next one